(gentle music)
- I'm here at the
Olympic Village in Tokyo.
And this is where around
18,000 athletes and officials
will be staying during the games.
But the concern is that there could be
a super spreader event at the Olympics.
It's raised a huge logistical
challenge for the organizers.
You can't really create a
kind of bubble situation
for the Olympics.
So what they're doing is
they're creating controlled zones
where they don't want people to leave.
(upbeat music)
Controlling people
and making sure that
they follow various rules
will be a huge challenge.
So we are going to see
how the organizers plan to make sure
the world's biggest sporting
event during the pandemic
doesn't become a COVID hotspot.
So this is where the
athletes are gonna be eating.
Of course, the dining
area is one of the places
at the Olympics where people
like to socialize normally.
But that's one thing that
the organizers want to avoid.
It's a potential hotspot
for virus transmission.
So most of the athletes will
be eating by themselves.
This is the fitness center,
and a special precaution
is here as well of course.
The organizers here say
that they will be asking
athletes to wear masks.
There's quite aggressive
air circulation as well.
But the machines are very close together.
So this is a place where
they are saying that
if athletes come,
and it is very busy,
they will be turning
them away at the door.
These are the condominiums
that the athletes are gonna be staying
in here in the village.
And we can get up to eight
athletes in one apartment.
(gentle music)
This is an event that's
spread all over the country.
It's all around the Greater Tokyo region.
It's even 500 miles away
in Hokkaido in the north,
where the marathon is going to be held.
So the goal is to create
this kind of archipelago
of controlled zones across Japan.
When people travel
between the village say,
and the Olympic stadium or other venues,
there'll be dedicated bus and taxi links.
There will be punishments
that will be imposed on
people that go into the city.
The organizers even said that
they want people to have
the GPS tracking function
turned on the smartphone
when they come in.
(gentle music)
The organizers have come up
with some very strict rules
about what people can and cannot do.
In general, in Japan,
people do follow the rules.
But there's some concern here in Japan
that people coming from overseas
will be a bit more cavalier.
So you have quite a large
movement of people around.
And that's a challenge
to make sure that those
people don't spread the virus
amongst each other,
and that we don't have a sharp increase
which could put the
Olympics really into crisis.
(gentle music)